It's called an inception module.
It's going to look
a little more complicated.
And you can skip this
section if you'd like.
It's not essential to
the rest of the lecture.
The idea is that at each layer of
your cognate you can make a choice.
Have a pooling operation,
have a convolution.
Then you need to decide is it a 1 by 1
convolution, or a 3 by 3, or a 5 by 5?
All of these are actually beneficial
to the modeling power of your network.
So why choose?
Let's use them all.
Here's what an inception
module looks like.
Instead of having a single convolution,
you have a composition of average
pooling followed by a 1 by 1,
then a 1 by 1 convolution,
then a 1 by 1 followed by a 3 by 3.
Then a 1 by 1 followed by a 5 by 5.
And at the top, you simply concatenate
the output of each of them.
It looks complicated, but
what's interesting is that you can
choose these parameters in such a way
that the total number of parameters
in your model is very small.
Yet the model performs better than
if you had a simple convolution.